so we have an interesting show you for
you today because while we have some
really cool Clips this one clip that's
maybe not a cool clip
I mean it's cool is that what we're
looking for you want it to be cool but
did it doesn't really seem that cool
anymore wait what happened we're gonna
be taking a look at a bunch of Mission
Impossible mask transitions today
is awesome trying to see whether or not
they did it practically or digitally or
maybe a little bit of both and a big
boat that makes a big boom
but in a way that might surprise you
[Music]
all right let's go
you'll never get what you want you don't
think I'll do it
this is from Mission Impossible three
you guys are very familiar with the
mission impossible series they have this
whole running gag of like changing out
these masks and they actually turn into
that actor but they have to do that
creatively to like kind of switch out
the mess so I thought this was a really
interesting one shot I'm not in the
field anymore oh okay here's a
retirement present I Phillip Seymour
Hoffman mask do you think he gets to
keep that no job there's always going to
be something between white and a woman
yeah ah oh but still mask okay a little
like a mask on a different actor maybe
ah but I mean That's a classic lifestyle
unless they did that intentionally
oh wait are they slowly transitioning
it's so good
is awesome so I also don't know the
exact way this was done but I'm pretty
sure I do so obviously it's the shot
starts on Tom Cruise and a fake Seymour
Hoffman mask right well it's a real
Seymour Hoffman mask
but then it turns into a fake mask after
the transition behind the dude's back
there's a hidden cut right there where
it just cuts straight to Black and then
it cuts to a completely different setup
so what I think they did was they
actually did the full camera move with
Tom Cruise there and the fake mask the
real mask
and then they do the exact same thing
again with Philip Seymour Hoffman in the
exact same spot so here you're probably
looking at Philip Seymour Hoffman's hair
his ears yeah it looks like it's like a
Compton face effectively I think so too
you think in CG approach maybe no I
think it's actually uh just a bunch of
2D compositing and projections I don't
know exactly how they're doing that part
of it that's kind of tricky but there's
definitely something going on where they
kind of like flattened his lips a little
bit will she watch watch his mouth as
vingrams touches his temples his mouth
warps oh his nose too yeah
yeah that's really clever yeah and
what's cool is like over time you see
more Hoffman oh my God I'm not even
sorry about that oh my God I'm actually
proud
solid I don't want to be around anymore
the biggest thing that is still left
over from the mask are the eyes
very like uncanny like like almost a
creepy kind of look and once Ving Reigns
puts his fingers over the eyebrows it
transitions back and that's the moment
we're like wow now it's fully him it's
so good because that's where your eye is
drawn anyway to his eyes so that's what
you're looking at as long as you're
seeing those gaps you're believing the
mask is on so it's the perfect wipe
opportunity since her eyes are locked
there anyway the blending of the mouth
and the nose like we we totally miss it
I love these mask effects Mission
Impossible Too having like mind melting
ones iconic
this is pretty awesome this is the one
this is the one that melted me
broke me
[Music]
oh good wow uh it's right in front
so good dead so it's like you know
clearly they're kind of like warping and
liquefying the face of one as this
happens but like what pieces from which
shot oh it's the arm the arm is the wipe
from one guy's body to the other it's so
smooth though so who's ripping the mask
off is it which actors are the one
actually ripping the mask off it's Gotta
Be Tom Cruise so the arm is Tom Cruise's
arm exactly so they must have done a
morph for the left shoulder because the
left shoulder is on screen the entire
time yeah it doesn't actually wipe no no
it does it does it does Wipe watch no I
did I did I saw the exposure
oh
wow
wow but the big tent pole effect here is
the mask though and I think it's just
classic warping an image as it moves
yeah that's that's it it's just an
artist who's really good at it and
probably took like a month to do it but
it's all lined up with a real mess so
we're seeing the real underside of the
mask and real hair on the left side
there that's just Blended in it kind of
comes from behind the dude's head a
little bit there and there's not that
much like digital manipulation going on
on the face most of the shot is covered
up by the folded over mask but there's
just a little bit just on the underside
of his eye and a little bit of his
mustache there kind of just stretched
down but that's a 2d effect the thing is
like that's kind of early in those CG
days also like when you can still trick
people and you're like how did you do
that because 3D wasn't good enough you
know you still had to come up with
something clever
When The War started
they've protected me did you guys see
the new trailer for The Creator I
haven't I've been avoiding it because I
want to go in blind well now you're
going to watch it so I read a user named
broke away Advanced caught this shot and
pointed out on the uh the filmmakers
subreddit like yesterday because this
came out a day ago yeah like yesterday I
just want to see if you guys catch it
and let's talk about it
ten years ago today the artist I've yet
to see any of this trailer I've been in
full blackout mode okay not the shot
whoa this is really cool okay pass did
you see it no I'm just I'm making this
nuclear bomb video and that's like the
perfect b-roll yeah but go back again
the shot after nuclear bomb shot that
one yeah I mean it's cool is that is
that what we're looking for
coolness because I found it can we pause
on it you want it to be cool but
it doesn't really seem that cool anymore
wait what happened what explosion does
that look like in recent memory oh
you're talking about Beirut
wait
they use the explosion
from Bay the actual footage of Beirut
and composited it into
yeah I don't know about that one what do
you mean here's the movie frame here's a
Beirut frame look at the lens layer
across the cloud
I don't think that
but you can see you can literally see
like behind the CGI futuristic buildings
are the exact buildings like you can see
that little like yellowish building with
like little top on it right next to that
antenna
it's just don't do
this man you got an emotional reaction
right it's like it felt very it's yikes
right yeah so putting words to that I'm
gonna hold off in like judgment for the
filmmakers for a second just for me for
my enjoyment of a movie I want to go in
and have fun I want to watch things I
want to think these are cool yeah and
when it's actual footage from an actual
tragedy it's not cool anymore I don't
enjoy it whatever the filmmakers are
wanting to do like I personally don't
like it yeah it does it makes me not
want to watch the film I kind of getcha
because I mean a lot of why we go to
films is to escape reality and to just
even know that under the surface of what
our visual effects and really well done
visual effects is actual Devastation or
suffering or death even it just it just
feels It's upsetting yeah it's so not a
good idea you know some people brought
the question like what about reference
and things like that and like I think
like when you're looking at tragedy or
like footage of tragedy for reference I
think that's okay because you know
you're looking at reality you're you're
understanding the world right and art is
a process of understanding the world but
to use it as like stock footage in your
shot like exploit the footage of tragedy
especially when it's like kind of this
recent still maybe you're rushing to get
a trailer out you need a shot but still
it's like oh even that's even worse in a
way you're advertising you're like yeah
real quick let's just use that the
tragic footage just we need something
quick for our marketing and it's like
you know maybe the filmmakers are trying
to be like you don't want to hit I want
you to feel like the reality of these
nukes going off but like you got robots
in like sci-fi buildings they just um it
doesn't work for me you know I totally
get it doesn't work for me I'm curious
what you guys think you know let us know
let us know in the comments and uh once
again shout out to Reddit user rope Boy
Advance for catching this
my wife was watching the live action
remake of Beauty and the Beast when the
Be Our Guest song came up I was actually
pretty Blown Away by The Sims uh not the
game but the physics Sims in the uh in
the movie and the very first thing I
thought of when the sequence finished
was I should show this to Jordan oh
that's really sweet have you seen it
before I've not no I've never seen this
and I'm apologize already we can't play
the music on YouTube it's just how it is
maybe it'll be a slide whistle cover I'm
you're welcome
[Music]
oh
I know it's a little weird that Disney
went like hyper photo real for like all
the remakes but the cgis No it's it's so
good though like from a pure technical
point of view even Artistry point of
view the CGI is still really really
impressive top tier yeah
[Music]
oh that's fun I think that's a real
drink she's holding do you think that's
air you're breathing right now
I like how they added stiffness in his
metal cloth coat yeah to make it look a
little bit more like just malleable
metal even though it's still kind of
moving like as if it's regular cloth
which it shouldn't even if it was metal
wow
the bubbles is that real why wouldn't
you do that real I don't know if you
couldn't oh yeah huh you can do bubbles
where we can do insanely photorealistic
bubble Sims they're obviously utilizing
every major branch of simulation so to
speak they're doing like the liquids
they're doing the smoke and the fire
simulations they're doing particles
they're doing cloth they're doing all
that fun stuff but what I love about it
Ren you pointed it out already is
they're playing with expectation of
these simulations like when those
glasses were first appearing it was
bubbles but they were almost dangling
like Vines out the glasses and that's
the real power of CG and simulation in
general is when you can get
photorealistic results but then apply
them in ways that are physically
impossible that's fascinating and I bet
they had such a good time doing this I
am curious about the the foam bubbles
though
look at us always picking up on the most
interesting things right can't wait
floating peacocks and you know all the
stuff is exploding and we're like the
phone bubbles show me this you're right
though the foam bubbles are like so
scarily realistic that it's like no way
there's no way there's no way this isn't
like The Lion King where everything with
CGI works for that very first shot like
there's real people in this there's real
stuff in this you know yeah I'm willing
to bet this is a real shot because he's
including the teacup yeah
I mean it's not even just the rendering
of the bubbles necessarily it's also the
simulation aspect of the idea of of a
solver basically a solver is looking at
the previous frame and the current frame
and the next frame and is going okay how
do we've moved from here to here we're
moving from here to here it's solving
using its knowledge of like kind of the
temporal evolution of your scene so with
bubbles too they're evolving over time
they're growing they're like folding
over and here water is being poured into
this big base so you're seeing it grow
and the the specular highlights you know
the Spackle almost like shining and then
popping and that would be such a
nightmare to have to design when you
could just fill a sink in the back room
yeah especially for one shot too because
the 3D models like you can render as
many shots as you want it's free right I
don't know ever since the whole Avatar
water thing I've had a little bit of
like TSD about like committing to this
is full CG so much of the rest of the
scene is 100 CG we know that because the
classes and everything is flying around
I mean there's like Hermione's real here
sorry Emma Watson is
uh the chair she's sitting on is real
the table is real and they're matching
everything to that to the point that
they can actually switch back and forth
yeah dude if this if it turns out that
this is full CG I'm just gonna stop
commenting about what I think
it's like retirement speech look we have
a pretty decent batting record all right
we actually do pretty well on the show
and and for the record for that that's
our shot we were kind of
I mean we're correct we kind of said
every option they just stuck by all of
them
this is not the first video you
know yours but you're not subscribed
subscribe
oh yeah yeah oh you still haven't done
it double dare you oh shoot now it was
serious triple dog dare you haven't even
hit that button yet
I don't think you can do it anymore I
have no faith in you to not subscribe
now and I quadruple but you won't hit
the Bell icon watch watch him not do it
all right all right
everybody's like man these guys are
really aggressive I don't like the show
anymore
sit down
not gonna stop
Speed 2 cruise control speed two have
you seen speed two no speed two was a
movie that nobody really wanted to make
from my understanding speed of course
was incredibly well received Keanu
Reeves Sandra Bullock everybody loved it
Fox was like oh it's a money maker let's
do this again and in the contract for uh
Jan de bont the director uh he was
obligated for the sequel but It All
Leads up to this dramatic conclusion I
don't know if you guys have seen any
aspect of this final thing I'm just
gonna have Christian play this and I
want to know how you guys think they did
it very smart of you to notice all the
ships the walls oh heck yes that boat is
coming in fast coming in hot baby
oh I want to see this I want to see some
sweet destruction oh yeah baby when you
go to these movies that's what you want
to see I want to see that money oh dang
wait that's a that's a real shot what
the heck all right all right this is
what I'm here for I want to see some
people build some expensive sand castles
and knock them over
not a computer though wait I'm not
saying anything bad right here this is
all pretty sick oh heck yeah dude oh I
never said it was gonna be bad the
movie's bad I guess speed up this is the
end this is what we build to I'm trying
to figure out what the scale of this is
because I'm like surely they're not
doing this at full scale this has got to
be miniature but probably dude how long
is that dock
that's right wow nice comp shot dude
watch this I'm actually really
impressive
oh wow wait a minute sure this is is
that full size I know did they actually
do it did Christopher Nolan Direct speed
two no way what the heck dude no way no
way that's just gonna be is that could
just be good coughing did they actually
just destroy an entire Port okay I
thought speed two was gonna be a bad
movie this is so far a good movie Jordan
as much Flack as Speed 2 gets from being
whatever kind of film people say it is
the ending good lord it's incredible
yeah it looks full scale what how do you
think they made it I'm actually curious
now that you say that so I would do a
miniature and I would comp people into
the miniature that's what I would do at
this point in time I would know that hey
we can count people it looks good let's
do a banging miniature let's plan out
you know plates of people shoot things
full at scale at the right perspective
let's stick them in the shot but the
destruction I would do as miniature that
was real dude that was it's a real
full-scale boat hitting a full scale
dock I would have some full scale stuff
that's like chunks of a scene you know
but like I wouldn't do the whole thing
full scale okay obviously I'm willing to
bet they did this at full scale with a
fake boat like the front of it looks
like a real boat but the rest of it is
just like a battering ram or something
like that it is just a front of a boat
there but that could just be the dock
it's the rest of it when it starts
hitting the city then I'm like no way
yeah you start hitting buildings in like
cars it's all real Jordan you Sly dog
it's all real it's all real Jan de bont
did not want to use Miniatures and this
set the record as the most expensive
stunt in history oh my God this cost 25
million dollars for this five minute
sequence and that's in 1997.
that is almost 50 million dollars in
today's money whoa and they went to
Saint Martin and they built out full
two-scale town oh so I was right they
built a town for this they built a town
for this they replaced all the concrete
with um sand covered balsa wood so it
was like exploding and doing all that
stuff and ren you were spot on dude they
rebuilt a false bow of the ship that
they used as a battering ram it was on
Rails that were under the water and it
led it on to land to pierce through
everything else and they took it 50 feet
at a time so they would go 50 feet they
would reset and then they would go again
and reset and go again and so there is
actually quite a bit of additional
digital work required to blend those two
things together oh interesting yeah okay
so there we may actually have been
seeing some digital manipulation on some
of these shots yeah the back 90 of the
boat is CG but the bow the false bow of
the ship was not accurate to the scale
or measurements of the real ship which
is what the CG model was modeled too so
they had to find a way to still tether
the ninety percent of the CG boat to the
front of the Bow Wow and just rescale
everything so that it worked so you're
trying to tether a CG object to a real
object that is the wrong proportion on
film with Jitter in 1997. so they were
actually on top of the boat here as
we're going across that shot looking
down yeah those are stunt guys actually
about to have the world rocked right
there then we cut to them being like
huddling under as the building is
crumpling over the front of the ship
they're there waiting for it happen
knowing it's about to happen soon I hope
I don't actually die here wow those guys
straight up wait that's real uh sheet
metal yeah that will actually cut your
head off if it gets pressed into it yeah
two stuntmen died actually no no I'm
kidding
no everyone's okay everyone's all good I
mean this car crash I mean this is what
makes you go this is a this is a crazy
stunt that guy drove the car into it and
jumped out of it and for real yep in
that spot this is really insane I really
respect this I mean I'm like when I was
saying build expensive sand castles like
this definitely scratched that itch what
a treat Christopher Nolan crashed a
plane into the airport but honestly this
was cooler yeah sorry Chris John did it
first they spent a lot of money on this
if your appetite still isn't wet you can
get even more on our extended react
episodes on Corridor digital.com
good use of the word what a good
pronunciation so I knew exactly how it
was spelled I don't remember when you
just said it there's no mistake I also
say witness day
if you missed last week's react episode
it was a banger you gotta check it out
it's right there if you like this one
you'll love that one check it out all
right thanks for watching see you guys
in the next one